we we talk about journalists sensing on
people but let's talk about the real
creepy 1984 stuff
his next story is from fox 13. teen
daughter
turns in family for taking part in
capital insurrection
they say an 18 year old girl outed her
own mother uncle and aunt
for taking part in last week's us
capital insurrection that left five
people dead
helena duke posted images to twitter of
her mother therese inside the capitol on
january 6th
hi mom remember the time you told me i
shouldn't go to blm protest because they
could get violent
this you tweeted duke in a video on one
of her daughter's tweets
therese duke could be seen arguing with
a police officer
another tweet featured photos of all
three of her family members inside the
capitol along with their names
hi this is the liberal lesbian of the
family who has been kicked out multiple
times for her views and for going to blm
protests
to care what happens to me so because
she has little in the way of financial
help from her family
duke has set up a gofundme account that
has already raised 40
000 oh my gosh i didn't even know that
part of the story okay that made it
hold on can we can we do an inflationary
comparison between 30 pieces of silver
and 40 000
that sounds about right at the moment i
have no idea how i will be paying for
college
as i have little financial support i
have a dream of one day becoming a
lawyer
but i need help to get through those i
have to attend college and then go into
the peace corps
show it on the donation page bravo you
have lost your mother
but you've made forty thousand dollars i
hope it was worth it yeah
well let me say something look people
should not have been storming the
capital
you know and and and these people uh who
committed the crimes and you know
we saw people die there they need to be
held accountable but there's something
particularly
twisted about turning in your family and
then
raising money off of it yeah if she
called the fbi
privately and said i know who that is oh
my god
that's still kind of like man it's a
tough question
but you you blood is thicker than water
there are challenges though sometimes
doing the right thing and holding those
within your own groups and your own
family accountable when they do
something very seriously wrong
it's another thing to post on twitter
hey look that's my mom yeah
give me money welcome to a brave new
world
well more like 1984 yeah what's your
thoughts on this luke says i know you
you've been 1984 man
yeah yeah your thoughts first look broke
yeah you just like
uh yeah oh gosh um
right there looks like i told you so
yeah it looks like i told you something
i'm far far beyond i told you so i'm i'm
i'm i've been there a couple weeks ago
it's more like
yeah okay um i think you know social
media also gives you a false sense of
community a false sense of acceptance
it all goes along with the trends and i
i i think i
and i think it's fair to say that this
person wouldn't do this if she wasn't
incentivized to get likes and tweets and
responses now of course it's also fair
to say we don't know the exact
relationship they had with
their their their mother or their father
so
it's it's not that you know we can't
judge here because we don't know what
happened back and forth but
for it to end up at this stage where
it's this public and this nasty
and and the media celebrating it by by
highlighting it and talking about it and
this being incentivized in the algorithm
it's something that's uh you know
awfully wrong in my opinion it is it is
the twisted nature of social media and
the current media ecosystem look at what
happened with um what's her face's
daughter who's uh kellyanne conway okay
oh wow
yeah yeah her daughter is like saying a
bunch of private family stuff and the
media is basically getting off to it
yeah and it's like dude first of all i i
gotta be honest
i look at george conway and kellyanne
conway and i'm kind of like is that real
that's upsetting yeah no is that real
yeah is this like reality tv it's like
big boss yeah no like they're a married
couple one's anti-trump one one's
pro-trump that's like a sitcom
yeah it really is huh he's hating trump
and she's loving it
it's the odd family and their daughter
is like and i have to pounce down tick
tock yeah she's making tickets
like yeah corvette corvette no but how
it's like
i find it creepy that this this kid can
get on social media and
the the big news companies are
celebrating
yeah while they're salivating they see
this little this young young girl she's
like she was like 15 years old yeah she
was
also like thinking from their point of
view like the kids point of view to what
luke said it's like
the sense of community they get from
social media is
way more important than their own family
yeah
which i think is like the sadder and the
more crave but like in no wall i would
like
think about the fact that oh twitter can
replace my family let alone the fact
that i would make money off of it
yeah so that's the more concerning part
it's it's the gofundme it's the paypal
post it's the it's the raising money
yeah it's the interviews that she gets
with these media hits i think she
already did an interview with like good
morning in america
so the girl who turned into a family
yeah so she's she's already you know
going big so i've got clown i want to
say this i'm gonna be speaking for the
latinos on this one
we would never do that because we get a
chance straight to the face that would
be a death sentence for latinos so we
would get the chocolate to the face
that would never there would be a wooden
spoon that's right
yeah yeah you want to give us the indian
perspective from the indian family
perspective we would probably like not
have social media until we were 18. yeah
yeah i love that well in the
cap in capitalist america children sell
you
yes yes well that's what it is though
the only reason she was willing to do
this is because she knew she could make
money oh yeah
forty thousand dollars that's a lot of
money i mean
that's a lot of silver that's more than
30 pieces yeah and probably like what's
silver at probably
like 25 yeah probably like a staff
position at media matters
yes something like that yeah well think
about it what's what's your family for
right
i mean first of all your family you care
about them they set you straight
but the point of the reason why we
develop social bonds as like people in
society is that
we survive when we stick to our families
now here's this young woman
who's found a better way than her own
family
see what's her parents what are they
really going to get for her she has a
place to stay if she's ever kicked out
she'll never be homeless
yeah but if she sells them and she sells
them you know for for 4
40 000 pieces of green paper
she gets 40 000 bucks that's more than
her family could offer
think about this if protecting your
family provides
certain resources for you to survive and
selling them out provides more
you can see what some people are willing
to do to get that right that's twisted
stuff man
this is yeah i mean it's a big part of
what we've seen with like black lives
matter want to disrupt the nuclear
family yeah it is all good for that
ideology
your cause your cause is central to
whatever you stand for like it doesn't
matter like you're close ties it doesn't
matter what your family is it doesn't
matter your principle
if you're for this cause nothing else
matters well in 1984
you know the fictional book they
indoctrinated the children to be the
snake
making sure that they would get all the
adults in in trouble for
wrong think and and when you look at the
parallels i mean i think there's some
i mean i don't want to be hyperbolic
obviously there's not an exact
comparison but
there's definitely a slippery slope that
we're heading towards especially giving
all of our power
up to these tech billionaire giants that
are unaccountable
do whatever they want and control the
sphere
of conversation but not only the
conversation also
thought when you have that important
aspect of controlling what people can
and cannot think
what they can and cannot see you have
emperor
god-like powers that could influence
children in the most
awful god listen forgiving
ways that you can't even imagine what do
you think you know what do you think
jack dorsey thinks like if you were to
go to him and say jack
children are turning in their parents
for money
because of what you built do you think
you would care i don't think he sees
that though
i don't know i'm saying like if you said
it to him do you think he would care no
i don't think i would think would care i
think he'd be like well you know people
say whatever they want and you know we
discovered twitter we didn't invent it
so
you know it's a it may be unfortunate
that they do that that's that thing like
he
he pretends that it's still a platform
like when it comes to matters like this
but like when it comes to matters like
people on the right saying about things
like then he becomes a publisher about
it
but then i would then i won't allow like
things to like stand in my way
it was you know i think i i could be
wrong but i'm pretty sure they said they
discovered twitter they didn't invent it
oh yeah exactly
they fell upon it exactly yeah they were
talking about how people started
developing a culture on twitter like the
idea of the at symbol
was was created by users who were trying
to make it so when you'd search
you'd see you could turn some at
someone's name and the hashtag
was originally so that if you wanted to
find the conversation about it if you
search for just the word you'll get
everything if you search for the hashtag
you get
conversations just the conversations so
then twitter is like oh we'll
incorporate this
before you could click the retweet
button people would just copy and paste
and then put rt
and then
i remember that because as far as i've
you know since i've used twitter
they've always had the retweet function
but people still did rt and mt
to like share things and there's also
like instagram so it doesn't have this
stuff so their perspective is
we didn't do it don't look at us we have
no responsibility to destruction of the
human mind and
human society or they like it i mean
look if you want to reshape
a society you need to break it down
first and that's happening whether it's
intentional or not i'm sure there are
people sitting back
it's a good thing let it fall apart i
know for a fact many far leftists
have been talking for some time about
tearing it all down so they can rebuild
anew you know we're down with the old
and then they can make their new
glorious secular heaven yeah well
whatever they think is going to happen
yeah
but uh there's a there's a funny comic
you ever see that you see those comics
where it's the guy and he says oh no all
the time
yeah yeah there's one where he's like in
his room and he's like i want things to
be different
and the next one is him smashing
everything with a baseball bat and the
next one is everything just jordan he
goes oh no
different from one yeah right exactly so
you get these people who go out and
they're like i want things to change
smash fires and you're like
congratulations you got change and now
it sucks
yeah like like a like a mother-daughter
relationship like that's gone now
like what's going to be like
thanksgiving for that kid they don't
care because they have their dopamine
hit and they're going to go fund me
but i'll tell you something she's going
to be an adult and she's going to have
no family she'll be all over and she'll
be
and she'll be in like an old folks home
you know what's really going to be
interesting too about all this
our parents can rely on us but
millennials aren't having kids anymore
nope like the
the the child like the the birthing
rates like gone for millennials
where where are all these millennials
gonna gonna do when they're older you
know look
these regular these average people are
gonna find themselves with
limited or no savings that's one of the
reasons yeah millionaires don't even own
anything already
they're not going to own anything you
know you know what the average net worth
of uh 28 year old is this is outdated
there's a couple from a
from a year two ago negative one
thousand dollars wow
you know what the average net worth of a
30 year old is 40 grand
thousand dollars oh boy and then from
there it goes up to like 12 000
and then 33 year olds like you know and
we're just talking about the states
right
yeah in the states okay it's it's old
data and my numbers aren't
completely accurate but it's like around
30 is when they finally get out of debt
accruing wealth wow so these these
people they're not having kids they're
not having families they're not making
money
i can understand why they don't own
anything they don't own anything they're
renting
and they're going to be 80 years old
renting and then they're going to be
like
put my parents and there's not going to
be anybody to help them
they're not going to be able to afford
it they're not gonna have any kids
there's gonna be a lot of cats
yep yep yeah but is it gonna wipe your
butt probably not is the cat going to
help you in your wheelchair down the
stairs oh they will eat you take you out
to the you know get breakfast
or he's gonna sit there wasting away and
another factor too tim i think what
we're seeing with the with this pandemic
and something that we've already been
seeing with the millennial trend is
we're actually going to see
less families with the millennials so
we're not going to have that structure
family
mom and dad at home working and just
having that
i think we're not even going to have
that so i would expect as we kind of
keep going on that crime is going to
keep going up divorce is going to maybe
people are getting married less and
the whole family structure in america
just seems like it's becoming like this
old idea now now it's radical to be like
i want to start a family and you don't
want to have kids and stuff that's just
that
that that seems radical now it's and the
really we need the really scary part is
is there's a lot of
undertones there's a lot of propaganda
subliminally especially in hollywood
incentivizing a lot of this stuff trying
to make it popular popular trying to
glorize it but in reality it's going to
cause a lot of human suffering
and it's going to make a lot of people
dependent and weak
in a way that they could be taken
advantage of by some of the same special
interests
according to my own personal opinion
that that we'll dive
in on this forsaken person who's
downtrodden
who's downtrodden by the ideas that they
put out that they benefit from that
suffering
so we have to understand this is a big
cycle that needs to be exposed let's
think about these parents
this girl turns her parents and she
makes 40 grand what do they do now
they're they're excised from polite
society they're called terrorists
they're facing you know
they're probably gonna face some kind of
charges they probably can't work again i
mean well they're gonna they're gonna
have to
these people won't just cease to exist
no they're gonna need food
they're gonna need access i think you
know there's there's talk about
this this this uh collapse of the united
states i did a segment earlier
china are the people in china are
flocking to buy this book
that predicted the demise of the u.s 30
years ago what is a family to do
if they've been removed from everything
they can't get jobs they're going to
find a way
and they're going to find their own
parallel economy
to make money cryptocurrency could maybe
help but that just leads us to this
reality
where you're going to have blue states
saying we don't want to work with you
and red state's saying it's fine
i mean think about this this woman's
going to be able to go to wyoming or
west virginia find a job
they're going to be like we like trump
too by all means come here and work
she's not going to do that in new york
city true so the the trump supporters
and the republicans and the right
the red states are going to become
entrenched and the blue states are going
to become entrenched
and if you're a trump supporter you live
in new york you're probably already gone
yeah
so we're seeing the ideological divide
is getting worse
geographically now and we're probably
getting that getting to that point where
things are going to fall apart
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe
hit the like button hit the notification
bell and we are also available on all
podcast platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time
you